[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour
chers à ma porte et le jour du mariage
ou un film là on a un frère tu as pleuré
là où tu aurais pas dû pleurer comme ça
frère mais j'ai passé six ans si tout
seul ouais mais free alamo et gül et la
maintenance est trop franchement tu t'es
foutu les naufragés même si j'ai pas
comment tu as fait mais tu as plus de
dignité frère j'espère que personne a
publié deux vidéos
hommage et face
c'était marrant frère sur ce thème
jerem je sais que la situation les
records et les horribles frère s'est
gelé souhaiterait même pas à mon pire
ennemi ce qui t'arrive c'est un truc de
fou franchement que je sais que tu es de
mère nature à ce que les airs mais il
faut être pragmatique la lune de miel
qui vous est offerte on va pas pouvoir
l'annuler donc autant qu'on y avait
peut-être toi et moi ça ferait du bien
tout le projet comporte en vrai
je connais je suis tentée ouais je sais
où je te le dis la vérité et j'ai pas la
tête un voyage et ouais phase i avec
fanny non d'enfance oui mais non voilà
j'apprends tous les jours on mange
ensemble odorant centralisée finira dans
l'ensemble mahmoud chammam
c'était quand même s'ils ont droit en
vrai si je devais voyager leur voyage en
solo j'ai besoin de nous retrouver
je t'offre une lune de miel est en train
de faire le make up with virtual bridges
ou bouger sous l'eau la
non adaptés vraiment ingrat france ça
c'est que je suis acquitté barré par est
non non excusez moi j'ai encore pleurer
non chauffés rima meriva il va commencer
c'est pourquoi je partirais avec toi
alors tout le monde amis parce que c'est
moi frère qu'il cherchait à ce que les
gens mettent de l'argent dans ta
carrière tu crois que l'iran voulait
payer pour toi presse n'a pas beaucoup
d'amies jérémy je te le dit prêt et je
suis privé du canton il a mis qu il a
promis quant à quentin la famille il a
pas mis côte à
commencé j tu as su de tout le monde
pour qu'il mette un peu d'argent jérémy
basique au tfc tour des trucs comme ça
grave on va la jouer honnêtement si je
pars avec lui comme une piste d'argent
et bah c'est moi qui n'ai plus d'argent
frais
ce qui s'est fatigué je vais choisir
facilement
c'est le meilleur
tu rigoles tué partir en vacances avec
ma femme tu es con quoi il souhaiterait
[ __ ] plos histoire tour supplémentaire
d'approcher au plus près la vie du
marquis murray dès qu une bouilloire une
demande à la caf un mois que je fais des
trucs comme ça on sera en voyage quand
même pas je vais t'envoyer des
storyboards palais on va profiter
arrêtez monsieur
[Musique]